المحكمه العليا الامريكيه امام قرار وصف
بالتاريخ سيعيد تشكيل عالم الانترنت عبر
اعاده النظر في الماده 230 من قانون اصلاح
الاتصالات السلكيه واللاسلكيه الامر الذي
سيغير طريقه الحديث عبر الانترنت ومواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي الى الابد
[موسيقى]
سيقرر القضاه ما اذا كانت عائله طالب
جامعي امريكي قتل في هجوم ارهابي في باريس
يمكنها مقادرات جوجل التي تمتلك موقع
يوتيوب بسبب الادعاءات بان خوارزميه توصيه
منصه الفيديو ساعدت المتطرفين في نشر
رسالتهم اما القضيه الثانيه فهي ضد شركه
تويتر وتركز ايضا على مسؤوليه الشركه عن
المحتوى المنشور على منصه التغريدات
القصيره
[موسيقى]
26 كلمه وضعت في قانون لاصلاح الاتصالات
السلكيه واللاسلكيه عام
1996 سمحت لشركات مثل جوجل وتويتر وفيسبوك
بان تصبح عملاقه فهذه العباره القانونيه
حمد هذه الشركات التي تستضيف التريليونات
الرسائل من المقادات من قبل شخص يشعر بانه
مظلوم بسبب شيء نشره شخص اخر سواء كانت
شكواه مشروعه ام لا
يرى البعض ان تويتر والفيسبوك ومنصات
التواصل الاجتماعي الاخرى اساء استخدام
هذه الحمايه ويجب ان يفقدوا هذه الحصانه
خاصه ان الماده 230 تسمح للمنصات
الاجتماعيه بتعديل خدماتها عن طريق ازاله
المشاركات التي تنتهك المعايير الخاصه
بالخدمات طالما انها تتصرف بحسن النيه
سليمان صباح العربيه واشنطن